cats and dogs cooperating and zombie
versions of Master Chief Princess Peach
and Pikachu it's episode 10 of IMG
here's something for people who like
silly bands but also like to keep their
wrist jewelry x-rated
and how can I keep my data safe oh I
know perfect I just learned this
yesterday but the same woman who
designed the cards and Microsoft Windows
solitaire also designed the classic Mac
icons last week BuzzFeed assembled a
gigantic collection of the geekiest and
sexiest burlesque shows around I'm
really glad that these things exist but
I think they went a little bit too far
with Chewbacca speaking of things that
are terrifying
let's get Halloween this pumpkin looks
pensive maybe stoic you would never
guess though that he was carved with
gunfire oh these pumpkins are cute
what's that boy does that pumpkin look
like you it can't hide behind it still
looks like you dr. coolsex went to
Zombie Khan and when I saw this
collection of the 27 best zombie
costumes I got jealous when it comes to
Batman costumes this is the easiest and
best way to do it or if dogs are more
your style check out these costumes from
Tompkins Square Park dog parade this
week tron Antwon and a horse carrying a
cowboy who I think might be taking a
dump
it's time for some IMG secret knowledge
now
click this button to find out the best
way to keep someone busy
cosplay can be pretty sad unless you get
to pose with Stanley at DragonCon
cosplay can also be incredibly awesome
the girl wearing these costumes also
made them you can find her it's secret
life of a bio nerd I've been following
her for a while and her stuff is
incredible so click here to go check it
all out don't forget about Facebook comm
/ Vsauce gaming where you can see even
more images and submit your own until
next time thanks for watching just are
you still there okay great great
now all joking aside click this button
to really see how to keep someone busy
Oh